[Musique]
1931 au tout nouveau mais police gardens
une foule record de plus de 15000
spectateurs assistent à un match entre
les deux équipes canadiens les plus
célèbres il a dit hey légendaire aînés
[Applaudissements]
toronto et montréal se livrent des
batailles mais mort en 1951 l'aimé
police battre les canadiens en finale
mais montréal prépare sa revanche
[Applaudissements]
ces contrées mais bon vivre ce que les
glorieux remportent leur quatrième et
cinquième coupe stanley d'affilée en
1959 et 60 et c'est très valorisant de
savourer la victoire devant l'ennemi
juré de toronto a serré n'est jamais tes
suis content de ma vie les
confrontations toronto montréal ont
toujours la cote des événements
historiques s'est produit pour la
première fois dans l'histoire un gardien
du parc un masque en séries
éliminatoires
outre jacques plante maurice richard
c'est de ce procès l'anc est déjà
inscrit cinq buts lors d'un match
éliminatoire contre toronto
quant aux leafs et contre le ch qu'ils
ont gagné la coupe stanley pour la
dernière fois en 1967
le tricolore détient mince avantage de
huit victoires en 15 séries contre
toronto
mais les deux derniers affrontements se
sont soldés par des balayages le moment
gratuit les fautes assez laid
julie victoire qui remonte à 1978 et 79
[Applaudissements]
un duel toronto montréal qui avait pris
fin dans le désordre la rue land and his
own forcé de calmer tiger woods qui
voulaient s'en prendre à d' officielle
qui l'avait puni en prolongation il a
fallu attendre quarante deux ans pour
assister au prochain épisode
jean françois poirier radio-canada m'en
vais